thank you all breasts thank you for
braving the weather and and being here I
want to start by thanking Sam for that
very outstanding introduction we were
saying backstage don't you believe him
you know a good kid good great speaker
and thank you for your commitment and
for being such a great role model and
also to Joanne for the terrific work
that you're doing to help kids lead
healthier lives I know the work isn't
easy but it takes parents like you being
engaged so we are so proud of you and
your entire family thank you for joining
us today I also want to recognize our
our outstanding Secretary Secretary of
Agriculture Tom Vilsack who has been
such a great friend and a leader on this
issue we could not do what we do without
all your work and your entire team we
are so proud of you we have been working
together from the very beginning and it
is always an honor and a privilege to
see the great strides that we're making
together so let's
and of course most of all I want to
thank all of you the advocates the
educators the leaders who've been with
us from the very beginning of this
journey as you all remember back when we
first launched let's move this whole
healthy eating thing was still kind of a
novelty back then if a school grew a
garden or installed a salad bar if a
fast-food restaurant started selling a
healthy item or business offered
employees incentives to exercise more
that was a big deal some folks even
warned me that taking on childhood
obesity might be controversial they
thought kids and parents should deal
with these issues privately others
laughed it off is not a real issue at
all well four years later that all seems
like ancient history today big chain
restaurants have whole menus of healthy
choices entire organizations are working
to plant school gardens and water just
surpassed soda as the most commonly
consumed beverage in America yay
and today folks are really starting to
think about what they eat and how active
they are so they are scrutinizing labels
they're asking questions that they're
changing what they feed their families
and just as we no longer smoke or drink
when we're pregnant just as we no longer
let our kids ride their bikes without a
helmet or sitting back seat of the car
without a car seat today we know that we
can no longer let our kids eat whatever
they want because now we know better now
we've seen the devastating effects that
poor nutrition has on their health and
this new approach to eating and activity
is not just a fad and it's no longer
just a movement instead here in America
healthy habits are becoming the new norm
and nowhere is that more clear than on
our schools which have been a core focus
of let's move right from the very
beginning see let's move is based on a
very simple idea that parents should be
in control of their kids health and
their good efforts at home shouldn't be
undermined when they send their kids off
to school parents have a right to expect
that during the school day their kids
will have food that meets basic
nutrition standards and they'll have a
chance to maybe move around a little bit
while they're there too and that's why
we launched let's move active schools
and today more than 6,500 schools are
bringing physical activity back into the
classrooms and because of the child
nutrition bill we passed back in 2010
today nearly ninety percent of our
schools ninety percent of them have
already implemented implemented new
school lunch standards and with the hard
work of so many administrators and chefs
nutrition professionals and others these
schools have literally transformed their
menus they're serving more fruits and
vegetables more whole grains and more
lean protein and starting next fall
they'll be offering only healthy snacks
and beverages in their vending machines
as well so this is a big deal and so far
these changes have
a resounding success in fact in a number
of American School District's places
like Dallas Orlando Cincinnati although
they're not changing charging any more
for their lunches they're actually
making more money because more kids are
participating in the school lunch
programs so we're making some real
strides in our schools and that's why
I'm thrilled to continue this progress
with two very important announcements
we're making a day the first is that
we're issuing new school wellness
guidelines to help build healthier
learning environments for our kids and
as part of this effort will be
eliminating advertisements for unhealthy
food and beverages in our schools
because I think we can all agree that
our classroom should be healthy places
where kids are not bombarded with ads
for junk food and these new marketing
guidelines are actually part of a
broader effort to inspire companies to
rethink how they market food to kids in
general because the fact is today the
average child watches thousands of food
advertisements each year and eighty-six
percent of these ads are for products
loaded with sugar fat or salt by
contrast our kids see an average of just
one at a week for healthy products like
water fruits and vegetables just one so
that's why we convene the first-ever
White House summit on food marketing to
children while I urged businesses to
stop marketing unhealthy foods to our
kids and do more to get kids excited
about healthy foods and that same
principle should apply to our schools
our second announcement today focuses on
school breakfast and I cannot possibly
overstate how important this is because
right now millions of children in this
country are showing up to school hungry
every day and too many kids aren't
eating breakfast even when it's provided
because they feel like there's a stigma
with participating in the school
breakfast program
and this is happening here in the
wealthiest country on Earth and it's
intolerable and that's why we're
expanding our school breakfast program
ensuring that nearly 9 million kids in
22,000 schools start their day with a
nutritious breakfast and as you all know
this doesn't just affect their health
that affects their performance in school
in fact a recent studies show that kids
who eat a healthy breakfast before 17.5
percent better on math tests and they
have fewer disciplinary problems so this
is critical for our kids future and it's
also critical for the future of our
country because healthy and well
educated kids are more likely to become
healthy well it eight adults who will
build a productive workforce and a
vibrant economy for generations to come
so with these two announcements today
and the initiatives we've launched these
past four years we are well on our way
to building healthier schools for all of
our children and and I want us to just
take a moment to really think about what
this will mean for our kids in the years
ahead children born today will be
accustomed to eating healthy food during
the school day so for them the norm will
be fruits and vegetables and not chips
and candy and instead of sitting
endlessly at their desks with no breaks
the norm will be kids up and moving
throughout the day in gym and recess and
during breaks in between lessons and to
the extent these kids are seeing
advertisements those ads will be for
healthy products so hopefully at the
grocery store they'll be begging us for
items from the produce aisle rather than
the snack food aisle because that's what
they're seeing on TV and if we keep
coming together and working together all
of this will be the new norm for our
kids here in this country and for our
youngest kids this might be all they'll
ever know and these changes will shape
their habits and
for the rest of their lives including
what they buy and feed their own kids in
the years to come so if there is anyone
out there who is thinking to themselves
well a few years this lady will be gone
and this let's move thing will finally
be over so we can go back to business as
usual if you know anyone out there who
might be thinking that way you might
want to remind them that I didn't create
this issue and I'm not the one who's
truly driving it forward all of you are
and that's really my message to all of
you today keep on doing what you're
doing because with every healthy choice
you make in the grocery store or at a
restaurant you're making a statement
about the food you want for your kids
and while your kids might grumble at
first when you serve in this food you
know that if you stand firm they'll
adjust that's our job as parents to hold
steady through the whining we do it all
the time no child wants to brush their
teeth or go to the doctor for shots but
we make them do these things anyway
because these are the norms for keeping
our kids healthy and healthy eating and
physical activity are really no
different these are becoming the new
norms for raising healthy kids so we
need to keep it up we need to keep on
coming up with new ideas to get kids
excited about healthy habits
particularly in our schools so many of
you are leading the way for example at
Marshall High School in Virginia kids
actually wrote and performed a rap song
and that's wrapped with aw and the goal
was to get their classmates excited
about healthy eating and here's one of
the lyrics that I love if I'm going to
help my brain come to fruition I'm going
to have to feed it quality nutrition we
love the cookies but they're not
sufficient we need vetti veggies to make
our bodies efficient roll my chicken in
a wrap don't jam it in a nugget
get hyped for healthy snacks and fresh
food we love it pretty good
love that don't jam it in a nugget not
my chicken this is just one example of
the explosion of good ideas in our
schools and to celebrate the 4th
anniversary of Let's Move I am asking
folks across America to get up and show
me how you move show me the fun creative
things you're doing in your home schools
and communities to get kids excited
about eating healthy and being active
show me how you move I want you to tweet
it Facebook it Instagram it with the
hashtag let's move so that everyone can
see how you're moving towards a
healthier future if we get enough of a
response might have a little surprise
from the President and the Vice
President I'm just saying and I asked
you to do this not just to celebrate our
progress but to motivate us for all the
work that still lies ahead because while
childhood obesity rates are beginning to
fall we still have a long way to go
before we solve this problem once and
for all and that's what the next three
years will be all about they'll be about
pushing forward to reinforce these new
norms because we have come so far so we
can't slow down and we can't turn back
now so we have to understand there's a
lot at stake not just for our kids
health and success but for the success
of our entire country so we need to keep
pushing and innovating and inspiring
each other to do more for our next
generation and if we do that I am
confident that we can give our kids the
happy healthy healthy futures they so
richly deserve so I look forward to
working with all of you together I'm
excited to see how everybody's moving
out there throughout the country and I
can't wait to see everything we achieved
together in the years to come so thank
you all again for your dedication and
God bless you take
you